okay this is bigger than Trump this is
about a fundamental change in
geopolitical power and Trust and I'm
talking about the embarrassment on the
national stage that is the presidency of
Donald Trump I told you upon the
election of Donald Trump that the new
leader of the free world this is a sort
of colloquialism that was first used
during the Cold War historically the
President of the United States under
Trump the leader of the free world would
not be Trump it would be German
Chancellor Angela Merkel and a couple of
weeks ago I told you that we now have a
significant polling data pointing out
that Donald Trump has already ruined
America's reputation around the world
Pew Research survey surveyed people in
37 countries asking them how are you
feeling about the United States since
Donald Trump took office and confidence
in the United States the reputation of
the United States has fallen off of a
cliff since Donald Trump became
President of the United States and now
according to a new Pew Research survey
we've learned that most g20 countries
trust Angela Merkel / Donald Trump to
handle foreign affairs now that might
not be surprising because you might say
well the entire world has an anti Trump
anti-american bias not so when we look
at that that is not the only issue when
we consider that even in the United
States you have Americans trusting
Angela Merkel more than our own
presidents to handle foreign affairs and
not by a slim margin 56% of Americans
trust on d'leh Merkel to handle foreign
affairs only 46% of Americans trust
Donald Trump to handle foreign affairs
interestingly which countries trust
Trump more than Merkel well at the top
of that list is Russia followed by India
and South Africa so it's very easy to
just write this off as Oh Europe and
South America are sissies and losers and
Low Energy whatever but even Americans
trust someone else over our own leader
to handle foreign affairs well at first
I thought maybe this just has to do with
animosity towards one's own leader right
but if you look at Germany they trust
Merkel more so than Trump 81% to 11%
signing it's not just an American thing
absolutely not and this is confirming
what I've been saying for months which
is that the Donald Trump presidency may
be doing what could be irreparable harm
to the standing of the u.s. around the
world george w bush destroyed America's
reputation around the world not as much
as Donald Trump already has and it took
almost all eight years of Barack Obama
in office to make up for that Donald
Trump is going above and beyond the
damage that george w bush did and will
this matter I don't know I mean trumpets
won't care they'll probably feel
validated by this they'll say hey other
two other countries don't like Trump
because he's so good for the US that
it's going to be bad for them the
problem with that is that it's going to
affect trumpets no matter what their
opinion is right when China is the place
that other countries go to instead of
the US for major initiatives on
pollution or climate change or whatever
this matters because other countries
will no longer see working with the US
as the top priority they're going to see
working with insert other country here
as a higher priority whether trumpets
will even realize it's not good for them
I don't know you know after the election
of Donald Trump there was a lot of talk
in the media that the United States was
moving towards a nationalist streak
maybe moving inwards becoming more
protectionist on trade yeah you know
pulling out of foreign affairs a little
bit more not so much when you look at
these numbers and certainly not when you
look at the popular vote that may be
true in the Rust Belt but not for the
country at large absolutely no doubt
about it and there although what what
we're talking about this indifference
might apply to some areas of the country
there are people folks hey we're in
Boston Massachusetts trust me people
here are concerned believe me folks
believe me I'm glad to tell you that
today's program was made possible in
part by blue apron we're in the time of
picnics potlucks
dinner parties and barbecues and you've
got to have good food at though
and now it is easier than ever to create
delicious summer meals with blue apron
for under ten bucks a meal you get
seasonal recipes and the ingredients
perfectly measured delivered to your
door I have been trying some of the
latest blue apron summer recipes and
some of the really really great recipes
available in July include seared chicken
and creamy pasta salad with summer
squash and sweet peppers creamy shrimp
rolls with quick pickles and sweet
potato wedges fresh basil fettuccine
pasta with sweet corn and cubanelle
peppers and chili butter steaks with
Parmesan potatoes and spinach you can
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free of course
with free shipping at blue apron comm
slash Pakman I love that I don't waste
food with blue apron because the
ingredients are perfectly proportioned
for the recipes you'll be cooking you
will love how good it feels and tastes
to create great home-cooked meals
support our show by supporting blue
apron at blue apron calm /pa que ma n